[Musik]
hi leute ich hab mir überlegt es ist ja
so richtig apfelsorten saison und es
kommt so versteckte talente bei mir aus
turnieren habe ich jetzt gelernt nicht
nur familien kann man mit äpfel sondern
auf torten backen was eine überleitung
wir machen jetzt ein richtig saftigen
apfelkuchen mit einer apfel schicht mit
einem bizkit boden und mit sahne
obendrauf und hier ist das rezept für
mein blitz biscuit den zeige ich euch
hier ist viel schneller gemacht als
gekauft hier habt ihr ein warmes wasser
zucker mehl bisschen backpulver und
vanille extrakt ich gebe jetzt das ei
das sollte zimmertemperatur haben in
meine schüsse und schlag das zusammen
mit dem lauwarmen wasser einmal auf
höchster stufe und lasst dann in zug ein
riesen dass wilex hat habe ich auch
schon mit dazu gegeben und jetzt
brauchen wir eine messerspitze
backpulver das wollte ich euch gerne
zeigen damit ihr auch so ein gefühl
dafür bekommen wie viel das ist nämlich
einfach ein messer greift da rein so das
ist eine messerspitze die gebe ich jetzt
mit zu mähen und dann sehen wie sie in
die eier masse
[Musik]
so das war es auch schon nur ganz kurz
unter rühren bis es sich gerade so
vermengt hat mit der masse und jetzt
nehmen wir uns unsere springform da habe
ich schon ein backpapier auf dem boden
gegeben die seiten nicht einfetten das
ist ganz wichtig und meine springform
hat die größe von 20 zentimetern nicht
in das ideal da bekommen wir dann so
gute zwölf stücke raus und das reicht
dann auch dann kann ich auch schon
morgen den nächsten kuchen backen da
gebe ich jetzt den teig einstreiche den
glatt und backe das dann bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für ca 12 bis 14
minuten
[Musik]
zu der boden darf jetzt ausfüllen und
wir machen aber auch schon weiter mit
der absicht dafür benötigen wir äpfel
nimmt am besten die säuerliche und
schneidet sie in feine stückchen und ihr
könnt damit sie jetzt nicht braun werden
auch noch ein bisschen zitronensaft
obendrüber geben unschön verteilen das
habe ich hier schon gemacht
außerdem benötigen die apfelsaft den
habe ich hier schon in meinem kopf getan
hier habe ich speisestärke und vanille
extrakt und auch noch etwas zucker für
die süße so der herd ist noch
ausgeschaltet und gibt jetzt zum
apfelsaft einmal die speisestärke das
dient der bindung zucker und vanille
extrakt und rührt das einmal klümpchen
frei dann lass dir das ganze unter
rühren einmal aufkochen und erzählt ihr
dass sich die farbe verändert hat und
alles schön dick wird und an der stelle
kein schneebesen er benutzen den herd
ausschalten und mit einem löffel die
apfelstücke unterrühren
[Musik]
jetzt gibt's auch schon direkt weiter
ich gebe den abgekühlten boden jetzt auf
eine tortenplatte natürlich das
backpapier einmal entfernt und dann ein
tortenring drin herumlägen
[Musik]
so und jetzt geben wir die geballte
apfel ladung die ist noch lauwarm
einfach oben drüber
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die oberfläche noch schön
glatt verstrich mit meiner winkel
palette und an der stelle kurz stark
bleiben denn das ganze muss jetzt
natürlich fest werden im kühlschrank für
mindestens zwei stunden dann könnt ihr
auch den tortenring wieder abnehmen ohne
dass euch die apfel masse ihm geführten
geht und wir sehen uns dann in zwei
stunden wieder so meine lieben die apfel
schicht des fells das heißt wir können
jetzt fortfahren und die letzte schicht
auf die torte geben und dafür mache ich
jetzt eine leckere cent sahne und das
geht folgendermaßen wir haben hier
doppel ram frischkäse das ist einfach
lecker im geschmack und ein bisschen
fester
hier habe ich seine dies eiskalt die
gebe ich jetzt ganz einfach mit dazu
zum süßen habe ich hier noch etwas
puderzucker auch direkt mit dazugeben
und ordentlich zimt und wer mag auch
gerne noch ein bisschen wandel extrakt
[Musik]
jetzt lasst ihr die zutaten in der
schüssel einfach mal verwöhnen in der
küchenmaschine oder mit dem
handrührgerät erstmal langsam geht immer
höher mit der stufe und wenn ihr merkt
so nach 40 50 sekunden alles verbindet
sich und wird so ein bisschen fester
lasst ihr seine fest ein riesen und dann
nochmal volle pulle eine minute bis
anderthalb minuten aufschlagen und dann
ist die creme auch schon fertig und ich
gebe es in meinen spritzbeutel
[Musik]
vorne an meiner spritzte habe ich jetzt
eine große loch tolle gegeben damit ich
eben dieses muster hinbekommen und ich
spritze nicht nur eine schicht sondern
zwei denn ich möchte viel sahne creme
eine wäre mir viel zu wenig und gibt am
besten unter eurem tortenplatte noch
einen drehbaren torten teller
man könnte diese form nämlich ganz easy
hinbekommen und ganz am ende noch zum
drüber geben wenn dies möglich finde es
sieht nicht nur schick aus sondern
schmeckt auch lecker und jetzt könnte
sie eigentlich direkt konservieren
[Musik]
ich hoffe diese torte den namen
bratapfel torte mit sind weil es einfach
so ein bisschen ein bratapfel erinnert
und zimt ist einfach die perfekte gewiss
kombination dazu ein schatten was der
hamza mir während eines shootings jetzt
übrig gelassen hat sehr groß so ist mein
stück aber egal das ist das prinzip
hinein also ich wollte euch nur mal kurz
geschichten zeigen dafür nämlich am
besten weil die haut in die handball
haben das stück ist jetzt wieder so
ansehen nicht
ich wollte euch nochmal zeigen dass das
verhältnis von boden abgeschickt und
sahne creme einfach meiner meinung nach
perfekt ist ihr habt nicht zu viel boden
ihr habt nicht zu viel ab für schicht
aber gerade so genug dass ihr appell
technisch gesättigt sein und diese
geschichte ist auch nicht zu hoch und
nicht zu tief also wenn es genau so
macht wie ich dann habt ihr einfach den
perfekten was du gerade gesagt hast
abwehren afl traum apfeltraum und ja ich
würde jetzt gerne auch noch mal kurz vor
der kamera alle drei schichten zusammen
und sage euch aber schon mal dass sie in
der infobox alle genauen mengenangaben
findet und jetzt allen mal genießen so
köstlich ist es nicht so ein winter und
ihr euch jetzt ganz viel freude beim
nachbacken an den bisher hingeschaut
habt hinterlasst ein bäumchen nach oben
und dann sehen wir uns auch im nächsten
mal auf die skizzen bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]